a Ugandan official says seven Eritrean
football players have disappeared at the
end of a regional tournament the players
are the latest to defect from Eritrea
which is being described by human rights
groups as one of the most tightly
controlled regimes in the world and this
isn't the first time era trained players
have done this in 2015 10 players
refused to return home after a
tournament to qualify for the World Cup
in Botswana at last October 5 players
disappeared in Uganda in the middle of a
regional meet now Eritrea's government
is forcing footballers to pay a bond and
surrender their property ownership
documents before leaving the country but
it's not just footballers every year
tens of thousands of eretrians flee
mainly to escape enforced military
service and rights abuses a while Olo is
a lecturer at Keele the University in
England he explains why this keeps
happening and what the prospects are of
real change I think mainly because there
Israel is one of the most repressive
countries in the world where there are
you know widespread and cause violations
of human rights you have four slits
military conscription that is indefinite
by nature and economy that is not
delivering for a society that is very
creative and industrious by nature and
people are busy with leaving the country
to avoid the harsh political realities
and also the economic deprivations they
face by remaining territorial I think
people who have been observing the
country were hoping that a peace deal
between TOB in an entry would probably
you know open the political space in
Eritrea and give the returns a chance to
have an active say in the politics of
game country develop the economy but
unfortunately you know even after a
peace deal has been reached the traits
of a major military confrontation with
neighboring Ethiopia diverted the return
States continued its practices the
indefinite National Service remained in
place where there is absolutely no
justification to do so and at this
stage I think it's really very difficult
to see any hope
while the continuously appeals in place
for a richer to move forward